contestants on The Challenge though have
alleged that the onset behavior from
producers was nothing short of egregious
take this example from a contestant who
claims that she was eliminated even
though she got across the red light
Greenlight Finish Line with 5 Seconds
still on the clock it was then as she
was waiting to leave that she saw that a
contestant and his mother were still
being filmed and not only that but the
show allegedly added time to the clock
off camera just to feature the duo the
contestant claimed this kid is sitting
at the Finish Line he's crying and
cameras are on him and he's waiting for
his mom he added more time to the clock
for to get across because she was one of
the people that they wanted to be in the
show my mom she was like a Superstar
athlete like I just feel like she's
going to she's going to outlast me and
embarrass me in front of all my family